Today is Super Smash Bros.
Director Masahiro Sakurai Sora's
final fighter
announcement.
Well, each one is just
download content. The director himself says
that he has no budget.
This is the last of my introduction programs that were presented. It's
lonely. I'll also introduce the repair of the
Bee Fighter that will be added earlier.  Music]
than
[Music]
Masu th
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] It
's called a boom town from Smash Bros.,
but I can't tell you about the original, but it
's the founder of fps.  It
works or doesn't work on any computer
Yes Psychology is October 19th
The last fighter on this day will be delivered, so
the delivery of Smash Bros. Special will finally end
March 2018 after the first booby was
announced  It's been more than three and a half years even with the feelings of
It's long open and long
It's been a lot of
things to say,
but I think it was worth it to continue to offer some kind of festival in this game industry, but this
time it's
finally time.  This is the
last I will introduce the last one of the participating fighters
from now on.
Please see here
up
[Music]
Hmmmmmmmm
tee
[Music]
wh
yeah
Momo
I'm surprised, but even I'm surprised to
join the sky from Kingdom Hearts.  It
's the same as my company name.
By the way, the sky is the sky in English
. This is
a kind explanation for overseas.
First of all, from the introduction of the original, ah ah ah
Kingdom Hearts Store Since
2002, Disney and square
It is a work developed by enix In the action rpg series that explores
the world of Disney's hidden works
The sky is the
main character The series is diverse and the system and the main character
may change, but basically it is a
story of the sky,
but with the cooperation, the participation of the sky was realized here
.  I'll show you,
no, the person on the left, not the person on the
right, is the one on the right, so I think it's the last fighter to be in
the world of Smash Bros. with a keyblade
.
I knew that was the most desired entry fighter.
More than 6 years ago, when I was at Smash Bros. for,
I conducted a questionnaire called Smash Bros. Tokouken
, but the top character among the characters who wanted to participate in the war was the sky.
At the time of holding Ken,
we had a meeting with President Iwata, who
was alive, and the results were tabulated. The results were hidden.
I'm sorry I couldn't announce the result,
but I'm glad that I
was able to connect to today's result through Nagaki
.
I think you'll understand as much as you can, at least it's not the same as
having one more fighter,
but now I'm on the stage of
Smash Bros. I'm surprised, but with all the
help, three races.  I'm grateful that I've reached the point where I'm
grateful.
Let's introduce it immediately.
B As
usual, the balance may change because it is under development
.  In
this presentation, the voice of the sky is in English,
but Japanese and English will be implemented. Many of the
download content fighters
had a strong personality with elaborate flight,
but this time it is relatively straightforward.
I think that anyone can use it,
but it's not that it doesn't have individuality. I
think it's rather high.
First of
all, I'm good at aerial battles due to its rough characteristics.
The behavior is fluffy
and gentle.
Is it a big weakness? The weight is quite heavy.  It's light. The
4th generation and the child link
should be called sperm, which is lighter in weight. In
other words, this means that it's easy to be blown away. It's the
last color variation,
so I'll do my best because it's a fashionable sky
.
The face is the image of his life in the sky of the first Kingdom Hearts
. As the
later series grows and the hairstyle and color
will be different, please see
[Music]
1 p 2 p  The creation of 3 p 4 p
is the first 23 d In other words
, it's 10 days when it comes to 3 style costumes.
Each of
them also has a
fighter's part work pose.
It changes at the moment, but I think it
was very good to be able to suppress the four basic series in particular.
I
don't think it's
Sakuraka.
And the 5p school is
changing the color of each outfit.
Lofy is Kingdom Hearts 2 Brave Foam Style 7p is Kingdom Hearts 2
Wisdom Foam Hmm Tooth Pee is Kingdom Hearts 3ds
Ultimate Foam
This is the copy
timeless River Hmm-
chan and facial, that is, the expression is also dedicated
It's a luxury specification I have.
With this, it's always been 5 weeks for Fighter Spa
.
Fan
3 d
timeless River It
's
said that it's the most elaborate costume in
dlc.
I'd like to look back on the fighters who participated in the war, so I'd like to force everyone out, so I'm looking forward to working with you.
Although it is disadvantageous in terms of the speed of manual feeding, there is also the aspect that it is
easy to make it out of time because the attack is out for a long time
.
If there is this, it will
be more like the original movement.
Specifically, weak attack
sideways strong attack
normal aerial attack before aerial attack 4
Will be a triple combo as it is a Put it in
front and put it
in the air as it is In the
air, the
attack speeds up and the attack power is
low.  Can be used for order rounds in formation
My aerial attack can be used for off-stage combos
It is also effective
for ground battles by using both from small jumps
Small jump attacks only sympathize with the attack button and jump
button
Even just shaking it can be a threat to some extent,
but if you do not hit with a small jump color, it
will land before the third shot comes out.
If it is a non-hit formation, it may be better to stop the hair
[Music]
There is also another technique that stops the button in the middle of the combo, but it is a
bit busy, but
it can also be connected to the ground
combo by the sudden descent of the aerial stop.
There may
be a sideways strong attack combo Please pay attention to the first shot
. The
opponent does not blow off, isn't it?
This is a one-shot life. The
power that the opponent blows off is also different.
Attack Attack time is long and it hits continuously
.
You can use it for anti-aircraft as it looks, but
if it is close, it will involve the opponent on the ground.
Also, if you hear the accumulated damage of the opponent,
you can add a stimulus
. Today's craft
[Music]
Moon  I think it's easier to use with less than a single
light attack, and if you look at this floating and attracting miracle, you should be able to understand how to use
it
.
It's easy.
Lateral smash attack It's
a technique to hit after swinging a lot. It
's the main technique of shooting down in normal use. It
may be a little long-lasting due to the characteristics of the sky.
There are some
places where it is difficult to use, but it
is better to hit it at the center where
the attack range is unexpectedly wide.
Maybe
[Applause
] Smash attack Combo from a small jump
Jump  You can attack while avoiding the attack at your feet
. Also, the attack range including shock waves is
relatively wide
, so it may be used for Park
Combo for 1 fighter.  Next is an aerial attack. A
normal aerial attack and a front aerial attack will be a
back aerial attack in the future, or
simply a horse body and Takagi.
However, since the combo
is powerful, is there an advantage like other fighters
?
Aerial attack As
it looks, the jumping power is high as an anti-aircraft technique,
so the range that can be intercepted is wide
as a result. Aerial attack
This is
said to be a hurricane period in the original.  I will make
a dive attack while rotating vertically, but I will explain later,
but it can be operated that other fighters can not easily do.
You
can throw like this even in the original story behind the magic. It
's
highly blown away and you can involve others
. If the
top throw conditions are met, you can also use it for continuous attacks in the air
.  It's
easy to connect various combos because you don't start from scratch.
And it's an explanation of the special move.
Also, there are 3 magics such as the small and medium pick-up bus, the normal special move Maho, etc.
The magic that is always loaded in the accumulated damage part
is displayed. When you hit it
, the next magic is loaded by automatic switching with curl and [Music].
First of all, you can shoot
by hitting the button repeatedly with Phi flying straight to the side. When you stop,
Mr. Sugino
decides the egg and the reaction is large, so
it often comes to the opponent who is good at medium distance.
It is also attached to various attacks starting from
that.
Sandaga can be a house where lightning strikes are staring straight
. There are places where it is difficult to hit, but the
attack range is wide and if you hit the first one, all three
shots  It will be hit
by aerial activation, but the range
will be narrower than the company.
However, if you hit it well, the screen
can be used effectively for
Mr. Yoshida.  Be careful if you can easily restrict the movement of your hands, but be careful if you
like it.
Next, the Brizaga attack party is the narrowest, but
it has the feature that you can freeze the opponent.
It is better to hit a lot in the work area.If it is
frozen, you can hit the button repeatedly
to speed it up, but in principle, the larger the attendance damage, the
longer it freezes.
Naturally, you should give an additional attack, but the
damage under evaluation is halved.  If possible, it is better to
hit when it is released.
Each magic can be reflected. It may
be less effective for those who launch it due to its nature, but it
can also be in Kyushu.
It's
possible to get rid of a lot, but it's a shame,
but it doesn't make sense if you don't use it in the
prefecture
because it
falls into Massa.  Since it is physiological in the prefecture, it is better to
use it more and more within the range where
it is hard
to receive a counterattack.
I'd like to use it
because I'm afraid I'd like to use it.
By the way, my father, by the way
, it's a magical expression that switches in order even with
wear peel
.
This is exactly what it means.
Sideways Special Wazasonic 0 minutes It's
a technique that can fly to the method of my brother 3 times. At
first, it always flies to the side, but this technique
allows you to fly quite flexibly.
If you hit the button repeatedly just by tilting it in the direction you want to fly, you will shoot and fly to a
nearby
opponent from the second
time onwards.
It's a special move on Pikachu and
Geckouga, but according to Rokko, Shin is different between about.
[Music]
If you use it properly, it's a move that you can rely on for Rimoho attacks
.
If you hit the opponent, you should look at the state and continue to attack. I
think it's better to use either Yoko or Yoko
.
[Music] It
's a trick to cheat the lacquer.
The speed and distance will gradually decrease with each rush of the
store. Even if the store hits or is sealed, it will decrease
, so be careful not to expose the moon near the
opponent.
It rises while hitting the opponent continuously
. It
's similar to the link's aerial line disconnection, but it
rises even
if it's on the ground.
You can move slightly from side to side,
and as an important point that everyone should use frequently,
there is a property that you can tour Sasa Ueki
to a special move Sonic Rave at the top of the jump.  No
matter where you are on the screen,
if you use the aerial jump Erial Water Sonic Rave together, you can make a
lot of stations and hooks. It
may be no exaggeration to say that the sky is empty.
It's enough if there are about two rising elements in the house
.
[Music] Get
air superiority after taking air
superiority by jumping in the air.
Please do this, but it wo
n't work even if you reverse it.
[Music] It
's fine to
say that
you can swing
the aerial combo and buy it at an appropriate place.  I ca
n't help it. I can go home with a margin. The
opponent may not be so, but
it is a special move counter,
but the
nature is different from the counter technique of other fighters
.
I'm in trouble, but
it's not interrupted.
This is an empty music. The
opponent's posture is broken.
This reproduces the counter that was in the original. It may be good to
remember that the opponent is a little far away.
As usual, the higher the opponent's attack power, the
stronger the rotation
. It counters the front, so it
is hard to be attacked from the back.
Okura Tsukasa is a candidate for a
counterattack.  Isn't it? It
's easy to hit a close opponent because it attacks immediately after parrying
. In a
multiplayer battle, it may hit a third party,
but the attack Rico has increased by about 4 times
.
There is a point
I introduced the abnormal technique Everyone should have made it appear beautifully Everyone Thank you everyone
You may think that the last ticket is the last one,
but I will omit the explanation here
.
If you tell me only the name of the ticket, it is
called the keyhole seal.
Overall, the solo
can move with very original characteristics. Enjoy.
Next, I will introduce the stage.
What you can see in the distance from the bottom is
[Music]
follow birthday sound. In
Maleficent Ijo 2, which appears near the middle of Hearts after King, it was being rebuilt as a layered garden
.
When
it was rebuilt as a Radiant Garden, the
terrain itself was relatively simple and was in the center, but
one
follower fights while patrolling near Bastion
. You can get a glimpse of the original
terrain.  However, I
think there are many people who remember
this stage,
but it's not just about going around the follow-up battle at this stage.
It
will transition to the world in the familiar heart
. This is a very stylish production called 2 hearts.
There are various characters that
appear.
[Music
] You can enjoy various characters in these chairs.
Of course, it can be washed or the end point.
Then, I would like to go to the customary trial play
.
I was in a state like that, so
I had to attack them when it was far away,
but
I wonder what it will be like with the reordering rr, this
time I will do it because of my physical strength
.  And Sarah's aerial cathedral power  It's
a rule that doesn't go very much, but
if you finish with this, I think that you
will get a little ace-like production according to the original,
so please look forward to it if you can
.  It's
quick to step in. For the
time being, I'd like to take power with magic. I'm
counting
on it. It's almost black.
It may be that I have canceled the future
. It's a scent that is full of implementation for some reason,
but it seems that only Sephiros is leading a little
.
[Music]
Okay, let's put it together. Stay
still in the door.
But
both of us are on the
floor
Chimako.
It's okay to control where you want it. It's okay to have a big feeling.
Stop is good.
Public land expansion.
What kind of thing is
it?
It's the last time to play like this,
isn't it?
Next is the introduction of music
. I couldn't use the stations associated with each world in the original, but I
considered it from other
songs.  There are 9 songs in total.
We
have picked up representative songs that can be used in battle scenes on the premise that the regular time is follow-bastion
.
All songs are the same as the original sound source.
There is
a work called "Kingdom Hearts Melody as Memory".
If you play this, the
dearly br de-swing
version in that work will be added.
Is a laughing song and it was difficult to implement the original song,
but there is a song that I managed to write down only one song
me  This is the last song written by
Yoko Shimomura, the original composer
.
Thank you
to all the nucleic acid musicians including the original song arrangement.
I think
that the fans are pleased with the various gimmicks
.
[Music]
Western spirits board will also be added.
There is another
character, so the title of the work will
arrive in a cool fashion. If you
omit it, it will be delivered again because there is no Shimada.
Scheduled to be delivered on October 19
If you have Fighter Passboro 2,
you can interact with the fleet as it is
[Music]
Knitting stick
Unfortunately, I don't have the actual product at hand, but
Steve is
scheduled to be released in the spring of 2022.
It's decided that
this is exactly Alex
Barlex from above
and below and the following family books will also be released. It
's quite hot to see these as Nintendo figures.
By the way, the new ones that accompany the recording of this program.
There is information It
seems that various series of Kingdom Hearts will be able to play with Nintendo Switch. It means that you will be able to play up to
that Kingdom Hearts 3 by the cloud gaming method
.
There are 3 8 titles and
Kingdom Hearts hd 1.5 + 2.5
remix
This is a coupling of the first generation and 2 and
there are related works such as Chain of Memories
Next is Kingdom Hearts hd 2.8
final chapter Pro
This means that the
current star of Kingdom Hearts 3d is the main
3d Dream Drop
Distance comes out in see ds
And Kingdom Hearts 3 is the end of the
so-called Dark Seeker edition. In other
words, if you play these,
you can
follow all the footprints in the sky.  To experience
Saba g Volume,
please wait for the follow-up report on the delivery time, so
it's finally open
[Music]
The last broadcast of Super Smash Bros. Smash Bros. Special
is over.  I'm sure I'll be able to achieve it someday.
I've posted a screenshot on my twitter, calling it today's piece,
but when I look calmly,
I don't think it's taken from just one game software.  That's
right, it means that we have made so many things. Please take
a look at the achievements of the Super Smash Bros.
Smash
Bros. Special so far.  I think that
each character has a
person involved in the development of the
original game, such as the world fan of the original game
.
This work of taking care of 01 points and producing
it is rare and important that can not be experienced anywhere else.
I think it was a job.
Not only the staff, but also
the people involved in the planning including public relations, the people who
supported it, and the people who enjoyed it
.
Thank you very much.
I would like to say goodbye to the game parts, etc.
Thank you very much so far
[Applause]
up
[Music]
Hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
4 days
[Applause]
[Music]